est ce que tu es sage en classe oui
questure sur
sacha de temps en temps
oui c'est ça qui fait de temps en temps
tu peux tu aimes ça un petit peu quand
même oui
j'aime beaucoup ça pourquoi est ce que
les enfants chahutent
ils ont jeunes se libérer
je veux rire où
ça leur plaît
comment est-ce que tu travailles à part
ça
bien j'ai un bon classement
alors ça veut dire en somme c'est quoi
ça veut dire que à la fois on peut bien
travailler et puis chahuté oui
merci formidable cette méthode là dedans
oui squillaci qui vous la connaître
dans les cours des lycées et des
collèges
à l'heure de l'entrée et de la sortie de
la récréation on voit marcher ce que les
élèves appellent les pions
ils sont environ 20 milles dans toute la
france a exercé pour un salaire modeste
ce qu'on ne peut pas appeler un métier
mais plutôt une fonction temporaire
puisque ils sont en même temps étudiants
le pion n'a généralement pas bonne
réputation auprès des lycéennes et
lycéens
la raison en est simple il est chargé de
faire respecter dans les couloirs les
escaliers les salles d'étude cette chose
difficile à définir qu'on appelle la
discipline ce que tu penses que fait
important la discipline on est assez
qu'est ce que c'est parce que quand on
sera plus grand sans nous laisser faire
tout ce qu'on faisait on pourrait vu
devenir des voyous ça moi j'aime pas
bien apparemment tout de suite à
ya des partir de moyenne discipline est
quelqu'un qui dirige
alors être sous les ordres de quelqu'un
sait jamais agréable
oui c'est très important
mais est-ce que ça évoque des choses
plutôt agréable ou plutôt désagréable a
plutôt désagréable parce que tu penses
qu'on a forcément envie de faire des
bêtises oui toujours
quand on prend donc discipline
quant à nous on arrive surtout lycée il
faut il faut de la discipline
ça nous choque un peu plus en plus on
n'a pas envie de lui obéir justement
parce qu'elle est obligatoire
est ce que tu penses que on pourrait
s'en passer une discipline non non
c'est une bête noire mais on peut pas
s'en passer c'est on ne l'aurait plus ça
manquerait
bon monsieur est ce que vos parents vous
envoie pour lire des illustrés au lycée
non
par montfort et quatre pages
de suite aller au travail tu crois que
c'est indispensable les pions ou pas
oui c'est indispensable
popp a surtout pour nous mais pour eux
pourquoi parce que il faut bien qu'ils
virent ses titres à l'instinct
je suis marié et pour vivre en quoi j'ai
forcé de travail et
demander une bourse disant que les
bourses ne sont pas suffisantes pour
vivre à deux donc j'ai choisi le métier
de surveillant
pour pour vivre à peu près
convenablement je suis étudiant en
psychologie et en même temps sur yon
l'external
et vous prendriez tous les deux je crois
que non derrière là les deux garçons
jeudi les deux garçons derrière chez lui
en parler
j'ai pas parlé de toi
régulant les envoyons que tu connais
sont sévères oui monsieur courteau
surtout
lui il est sévère
qu'est-ce que tu trouve ça bien ah non
pas toujours ceux par exemple quand on
se met pas en rond ils nous collent à
tous les surveillants font comme ça
pas tous non mais la bonne majorité oui
et non quelques-uns qui ne comprennent
comment ils font cela là
bas ils nous laissent un médium est
possible de demander des renseignements
sans trop de bruit et puis quand on a
une finition peut expliquer pour essayer
de ne pas l'avoir
parce qu'il y en a avec qui on veut pas
s'expliquer du tout non n'est même pas
intérêt explique ehsanullah double ya
pas 36 solutions mon avis il faut qu'il
y ait à l'appui un système de punition
qu'ils soient pas trop absurde quand
même mais l'école sont absolument
nécessaire si on veut maintenir une
discipline travailler individuellement
le déjà répété cent fois qu'est ce que
ça te fait que tu es puni bon moi
particulièrement ça ne fait rien
je fais ma punition puis après
les élèves ils peuvent rien d'ailleurs
contre cette menace
ils demandent dans une certaine mesure 6
ni si tout le monde avait quelque chose
pour se défendre à ce moment là je sais
pas comment mais enfin
dans une certaine mesure des menaces
je crois pas d'ailleurs ça a abouti à
grand chose évidemment nous avec sa
salle et contentent ils sont six nuances
mais
combien de temps on peut pas toujours
rester sans parler parce que quand on
est en permanence on ne dira oh nous
mais toujours au silence complet
puis
c'est pas bien on est toujours obligé de
parler est-ce que tu connais des gens
qui ne put disent pas qu'ils arrivent à
quelque chose oui
je connais surveillants kelly nancy
c'est qu'ils arrivent très bien je
trouve qu'il est très très gentil très
bien il sait qui est bien c'est que j'ai
vu
quand il demande de se taire ou stay
cantine on sait pas pourquoi on est
comme si on on respecte le mans on peut
se tutoyer entendu
parler facilement
mais tu veux dire on le respecte autant
que ce j on respecte autant qu'elles
soient meilleurs thés verts
mais se ressemblent en nous
m
n'est pas trop sérieux et
d'un peu de liberté mais pas trop
pas trop
et toi ça te va ça
plaise
beaucoup plus qu'avec certains entre
surveillants
tu l'as déjà vu venir
je ne peux pas vous dire quand
je dis pas cela parce que je crois qu'il
est je crois que lui que calamity jane
j'essaie d'avoir une certaine autorité
basée sur la confiance
que je peux enfin que les enfants
peuvent avoir en moi mais enfin ça pose
un problème c'est que un surveillant
d'externat dans un établissement il
apporte pratiquement rien des enfants je
crois que l'autorité on l'a on
l'acquiert enfin les enfants en
confiance en nous et en même temps ils
nous respectent dans la mesure où on
leur apporte quelque chose de positif
c'est un peu c'est un peu le copain mais
à qui
novelli se dire que on s'amuse avec lui
on chahute mais
n'est des limites
ses limites la con respect sarr et ses
limites vous les trouvez de vous même
alors oui c'est ce que c'est ce que je
trouve formidable parce que avant avant
juillet je n'y croyais pas ça change un
peu plus que d autres ayant qui
punissent épique au dehors on peut pas
leur parler
c'est à dire qu'on sait pas si on ne
peut pas leur parler on ne va pas leur
parler parce que parce que antipathique
nôtre nous on sait pas si nous parlerons
quand on a des contacts souvent on perd
son autorité
envers les gens justement avec qui on a
ces contacts et ça c'est fatal
c'est pas fatale disons que
en étant honnête dans une proportion de
50%
alors évidemment ça après ça nous pose
tout de suite un problème pour faire une
étude par exemple
dépensé que si on relâche cette forme
extérieure d'autorité contraignantes il
n'y a pas de respect possible
pour les surveillants difficilement
jeudi et la discipline c'est la bête
noire mais on ne peut pas s'en passer
bon ça signifie qu'il faudrait trouver
une autre forme d'organisation
bah oui mais ça y
est tu pense qu'elle est trouvable
oui on peut trouver quelque chose qui
atteindra à la fois les les professeurs
et les élèves
et ça serait quoi
hachez pas vrai peut-être demandé à
beaucoup plus de gens à voir un petit
peu ce que tout le monde pense
on peut y arriver
je crois qu'il faut d'abord discuter
avec les élèves pour dire ceux qui sont
d'accord le genre de discipline qu'il
faut adopter
puis après on verra bien sûr
les choses qu'il faut faire les règles
réprimandé tout ça
oui tu veux dire que si on en discute
avec eux
on risque d'avoir de meilleurs résultats
sur parce que si on met tout de suite
comment dire mettre un règlement et nora
qui seront contents bien sûr il y en
aura qui seront pas contents leurs hôtes
en discuter dans chaque classe faire un
bilan à la fin pendant pas la fin de
chaque mois à la fin du mois où on a
fait le bilan dans chaque classe dans un
cours pour une permanence on fait le
bilan ceux qui sont d'accord pour ce
règlement ceux qui sont pas d'accord et
on voit à peu près ce une sorte de
sondage quoi d'abord on serait déjà
beaucoup plus content de respecter
l'ordre cycling
et puis
il écouterait mieux
tout ce ce qu'il ce qu'ils disent en
général ils le font
mais tu veux dire que s'ils
s'engageaient sur quelque chose il le
tiendrait oui
moi je veux pas
[Musique]